[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know if most people know
sao paolo antonio served five years in
the united states navy from
1978 to 1983 and i was talking about
army navy here sam
i am so patriotic when i like that
atmosphere
is just wonderful did you ever attend
army navy game
many times in philadelphia at lincoln
financial field
i i was there i i was there with the
secretary of defense and my wife we
we hung out with his wife and family at
the 50-yard line
uh it it's a it's a it's a it's a great
great event it's great fun but i'll just
say this and i love navy
obviously root for navy navy needs to
take a time out a double reverse
that results in a safety
uh let's go chase some submarines for a
while or do something come on
you were awarded the uh
uh service medal i believe is that right
1981 so supervising the rescue of
vietnamese refugees in the
south china sea explain the award
and what happened it's the united
nations meritorious service award given
to me
and my shipmates on the uss olette and
we were in the south china sea and our
mission
was to find vietnamese refugees
that were being preyed upon by pirates
at sea
pirates would uh have board their
their boats and take them and force them
into uh
servitude on on the high seas so we we
rescued them
many of them many hundreds of them and
uh brought them to the united nations
refugee center in singapore we ferried
them from the south china sea back and
forth it was a huge mission i was
i was a part of it helped supervise it
on my ship
and every one of us on the ship was
awarded that medal
many of us were ever get nervous
no i mean you know you're trained at sea
uh to be underway and no
never did you know and as an officer so
i was a surface warfare officer so i was
an officer of the deck
underway uh indian ocean pacific south
south pacific it's a it was it was a
fabulous experience to be among great
great men and women in the american
armed forces for five years
to serve alongside them be part of a
peacekeeping missions i i was lucky dan
and i never served during war time
that's that's the goal of anybody who
serves in the military is to serve
uh during peace time and uh i
i was one of the lucky ones for sure
and then you come back and then all of a
sudden how do you get into the media
after being in the military
i had already had a master's degree in
journalism
from nyu when i joined the military i
joined the military because it was a
family tradition
my uncle tony who was my
godfather was in submarine service in
the north sea during world war ii my
uncle sal who i'm named after was a
marine
in the korean war so um
all of my dad's brothers and my mom's
brothers served in either the navy army
or the marine corps my dad however did
not serve
because god rest his soul he was
four f'ed because he had cataracts at
birth
and so it was um it was a sad situation
for him he really wanted to serve
and um so it really was up to me as his
oldest son
and you know i joined at the height of
the anti-vietnam war effort
so it was not in vogue to come out of
college and go join the service but
that's what i did
i had an uncle who lied and he joined
the army at 16
and which war he was in the korean war
yeah the korean war was no joke and he
was in battle
i mean i yeah it affected him the rest
of his life
he got frost bit and he would always
have white socks on every time i would
see him
and like i can't imagine
the horrors of war at any age and he was
16 he lied to get into the army
and he saw a lot of battle a lot
a lot of stuff and we were never allowed
to bring it up uh
right did he so he survived and had a
whole life after that day
uh not a long life but he had a life
after that but yeah
he was in one of the bloody bloodier
battles uh what was his name what was
his name
uh last name was miller tom miller yeah
but my my father-in-law served in the
marine corps
in korea and was in the last great
amphibious assault
of the u.s military at inchon
and survived that assault and
we were never allowed to talk to him
about it yeah
uh all right i got sidetracked there but
uh the espn national correspondent
primarily covering the nfl nfl
matchup host and uh i don't know what to
make of what doug peterson said after
yesterday's win here
sal so can you interpret what doug
peterson is saying about who
is going to be a starting quarterback
next week against arizona
i think it's difficult to interpret but
one of the things that i learned
very early on as a reporter and i
learned it from
some of my mentors is don't pay
attention to what coaches say
coaches lie all the time
pay attention to what they do and so i
don't put a lot of stock in press
conferences press conferences
are good for copy and
uh you know talk shows and all that
stuff that's all good and
of course we want to pay attention to
what they say and they sometimes create
controversy
but at the end of the day pay attention
to what happened in the game and the
decision that was made
and for whatever reason whether and i i
saw what peter king said to you about
the fact that everybody's walking on
eggshells because of carson wentz i i
think
this part that that's partly true i
i think and i love carson wentz
everybody in that building does
and carson wentz is a tough guy and a
hard worker and a good teammate
you'll never hear me say a bad word
about him but i said three weeks ago
it was time for him to get benched like
donovan mcnabb did in 2008
a little time out uh now kevin cobb came
in
and of course did not display any kind
of talent
worthy of keeping him in the obvious big
gamble here is jalen hurts would do what
jalen hurts did yesterday and let's be
clear about
something let's be very clear about
something
jalen hurts won the game
the reason why the eagles won the game
was because jalen hurts
i want you to look you look at the
roster and the starting lineup of the
saints
camara sanders cook michael thomas
this young man traequan smith you go on
the defensive side of the ball
cameron jordan k quan alexander demarius
davis
janoris jenkins malcolm jenkins marshawn
lattimore just to name
a half a dozen on each side of the ball
dan name
one philadelphia eagle that starts on
that new orleans saints team give me one
i don't i can't come up with one
maybe jalen hurts over taysom hill
well maybe maybe that might be about
it so i mean if you're looking for a
reason why the eagles won the game it's
because of the performance of jalen
hurts and you know
the biggest thing that's out there now
is that the offensive line performed
better
for jalen hurtston well come on you know
the eagles were number one in sacks
and jalen hurts was not sacked yesterday
in the game and our
our stats department just put this out
moments ago
jalen hurts was pressured 14 times
on sunday of those dan the eagles gained
82 yards on those plays and he took
no negative plays on the 14 pressures
how much does management have to see of
jalen hurts
before they realize what they have one
way or another no one has said for
management what
they think at this point we're going to
find out
basically when they take action on hertz
and or carson wentz
but this idea that you're going to just
trade carson wentz
i realize it's a good poll to have but
i mean you know frank reich is not a
stupid man
chris ballard is not a stupid man the
indianapolis culture are a well-run
organization they've turned he's turned
that organization around he loses andrew
luck
goes through one quarterback they get
phillip rivers and voila they're
they don't have a they don't have a
weakness on that colts team right now
that i can see
so they're they're not dumb they realize
that
the better hurts plays the less
value wence has we can establish that
right that's obvious yeah
yeah yeah so that that may be part of
the reason why they're play acting
by not pumping up jalen hurts's
performance
that me but come on let who's zooming
who here let's keep it real
everybody can see what's going on you
plug in the tape you know that jalen
hurts
looked like everybody else was standing
still at times yesterday
yeah he lifted yeah like you could tell
even at the latter part of the
green bay game i i saw something like it
was
tangible there of a team that was like
whoa wait a minute here
and then it carried over against you
could say the best defense certainly in
the nfc
with the saints that that's what was
impressive that got my attention that
this wasn't against the bengals
this was against the new orleans saints
and
at times i was thinking do they have a
game plan did they have a game plan for
jalen hurts because it didn't feel like
they had one
defensive prior to that game sean payton
owned the eagles he was six and two
against the eagles
doug peterson was 0-2 against sean
payton
before that game i've covered a lot of
these games where i saw the eagles get
waxed by the saints
absolutely demoralized and here jalen
hurts comes in
and like you said he energized the whole
team that was actually a note i was
looking for in my notebook last night i
found it
that hertz has lifted the energy of
everybody
on the team everybody is just playing at
a different level
they're they're not looking at their
shoes anymore on the field
uh it's good what is the game what's the
game plan going forward i mean
everybody wants to hit the fast forward
button dan and i don't have an answer
for it i mean but
just hold off the idea of it's going to
be real easy to trade cars
and wets and those people who want to
keep wince
and trade jalen hurts those people need
to go live in maryland
because it's it's not going to that
would be a very difficult sell to this
fan base
handicap the nfc east the rest of the
year who wins this division
well washington has really you know they
they were a good team that first week i
saw them
beat the eagles up in the second half
chase young and that front four super
active
great front four but if they don't have
a healthy alex smith
they're gonna they're gonna limp to the
finish beginning
against seattle this week i'm covering
that game at fedex
i want to see after they've been on the
road at pittsburgh
and at san francisco how they respond in
this game against
seattle the giants have a quarterback
problem
the giants have a quarterback problem
because colt mccoy was playing
very well and he put daniel jones in
there as well he should
coming back from injury but mccoy played
a lot better than
people think when you plug in the tape
and you look at it i thought he played
smart
he was accurate with the football and he
took care of it for the most part
um the eagles have to get super lucky
and they need help
good to talk to you again sal uh we
appreciate your time as always and uh
hope to talk to you again happy holidays
dan thanks for having me thank you buddy
at sao pal antonio espn national
correspondent primarily covering the nfl
nfl matchup host